in the United States New York remains by
far the worst affected coronavirus
trouble spot confirmed cases erasing
above 93 thousand while more than two
and a half thousand have died nurses
there have been describing the struggles
health care workers face in their
overwhelmed hospitals you're definitely
walking into a war zone and we no longer
know what we're walking into we don't
know who has this virus we don't know
who's been exposed
we just make the assumption that as we
walk in
we walk in understanding that we're
possibly getting more exposure than we
already have
and we're burnt out we are we come in
every day and we're not getting support
from from our managers or you know our
government is telling us we can wear a
simple bandanna if we don't have a mask
the start of it makes sense we can't do
this we want to do this because this is
our lives we care we want to thank
people but we can't do that if we're
dying ourselves because the amount
exposure and the lack of proper
protective equipment so something's got
to give and it looks like it was
you